[Music]
[Music]
as i've watched and read people talking
about tenant it's become
almost a meme at this point that many
pieces of dialogue are difficult to hear
or almost completely unintelligible
this problem has been developing for a
while in nolan's work and it seems to
have really come to a head with tenant
but what's going on here
christopher nolan is working with
massive budgets and is one of the most
critically acclaimed blockbuster
directors working today so it's very
unlikely that this
is just shoddy filmmaking or an
oversight so there must be some reason
why nolan's films sound this way and
that's what i'm going to examine with
this video
is nolan doing this intentionally and if
so
is that a good creative choice thank you
once again to mubi for making this video
possible
i first remember hearing complaints
about the intelligibility of nolan's
dialogue during the release of the dark
knight most of the complaints centered
around
bane's mask muffling his dialogue now we
come here
not as conquerors but as liberators to
return
control of this city to the people
at this point i have to mention
something that actually makes discussing
this topic fairly complicated i can show
examples from these films but the
examples i show
aren't going to accurately represent
what it's actually like to
listen to the film in a theater i gave
him a humor setting so we'd fit him
better with his unit
he thinks it relaxes us a giant
sarcastic robot
because our sound systems are different
at home and in most cases the films are
actually remixed for home release
so if you're listening to one of these
examples and you're like wait a second i
can hear every word they're saying fine
it might be because you're listening on
headphones or better sound system
or just because the mix of the home
release is different from the theatrical
mix
and theaters themselves are variable in
how they
sound just because you went to the
theater and could hear every line of
dialogue fine in one of these movies
doesn't mean that if you went to another
theater you would hear the same thing
but i'll talk more about that later for
the dark knight rises while the bane
thing was
annoying to a lot of people it didn't
seem to really detract from the movie
too much if anything
people disliked it for other reasons but
the complaints
resurfaced with nolan's next film
interstellar this time the complaints
were louder and more common
and people felt like they were missing
key pieces of dialogue
there were some complaints about the
dialogue in dunkirk
but it's not a very dialogue heavy film
and so again it didn't seem to be a big
problem but then
last year tenet hit and rather than
improving the problems seemed
to have escalated at this point it seems
like even some people who are fans of
the film are open to acknowledging that
some lines were difficult to hear and
saying some of the dialogue was
unintelligible is a pretty
uncontroversial opinion about tenet
[Music]
what's going on here why is this
happening well
i think there are two key things that
are contributing to this problem
after interstellar the complaints about
the dialogue were so numerous that nolan
directly addressed the issue in an
interview with hollywood reporter
we made carefully considered creative
decisions there are particular moments
in this film where i decided to use
dialogue as a sound effect so sometimes
it's mixed slightly underneath the other
sound effects or
in the other sound effects to emphasize
how loud the surrounding noise is
it's not that nobody has ever done these
things before but it's a little
unconventional
for a hollywood movie this scene from on
the waterfront is a great example of the
kind of technique that nolan is talking
[Music]
about
[Music]
and this scene from terence malik's tree
of life is another great example
in both cases the filmmakers clearly
feel like the image sound effects and
facial performance are more important
than hearing the lines of dialogue and
they're emphasizing those elements by
taking away the audience's ability to
hear what's being said
nolan is clearly trying to use this
technique in several places an
interstellar like this one
you don't sound so bad for pushing 120.
[Music]
i don't agree with the idea that you can
only achieve clarity through dialogue
clarity of story clarity of emotions
i try to achieve that in a very layered
way using all the different things at my
disposal
picture and sound in theory i think this
is a
totally valid technique for example if i
turn up the music
[Music]
in sound design you're dealing with two
things the actual
intensity of the sound and the intensity
of a specific sound
relative to the other sounds in the mix
by drowning a sound we're used to being
able to hear
out with another it implies an intensity
to the second sound that may not be
there naturally
when i watched interstellar i saw it in
70 millimeter imax that would be an
important detail later but when i saw
complaints about the sound afterwards i
was confused i didn't really
understand what people were complaining
about yes i had difficulty hearing a few
lines but
like nolan pointed out i assumed it was
intentional and that those lines weren't
important
at the time interstellar came out i
pretty much accepted this
explanation but tenet tenet was a
different story
for scenes like this where you can't
hear some of the dialogue
you can't hear isn't really important
this is clearly nolan
intentionally obscuring the dialogue
nolan is playing with sound in an
interesting way
in this scene bringing the vocals of the
freeport attendant to the surface only
when he's really giving a key piece of
information
from their private planes of course
and to be honest i get what he's trying
to do here and i kind of like it but
that explanation
doesn't account for a scene like this
here the dialogue is pretty important
exposition
and when i listen at home with
headphones on i can make out what
they're saying
but when i saw this in theater i could
barely understand a word of what they
were saying
and that brings us to the second
component of this issue
can i recommend the taylor i'll manage
you british don't have a monopoly on
sniper you know
[Music]
when it comes to picture and sound not
all theaters are created equal
some theaters have much higher quality
top of the line sound systems and on top
of that how good the sound
is in an individual theater depends on
how well aligned and calibrated the
sound system is
in an interview with indiewire nolan
said this we made the decision a couple
films ago that we weren't going to mix
for substandard theaters
we're mixing for well-aligned great
theaters so when filmmakers are
mixing the sound of the film they make
decisions based on how they want the
film to sound creatively but they also
have to make decisions based on
maintaining clarity
across a variety of different quality
levels
and theaters nolan however is saying
that he's focusing
solely on crafting the experience for
top of the line theaters so a line like
this
[Music]
might be inaudible in a poorly aligned
theater not because christopher nolan
doesn't want you to hear the line
but because he's only paying attention
to whether or not that line is clear
in a well-calibrated well-aligned
top-of-the-line theater
so every time he's pushing the
intelligibility of the audio
to its edges he risks losing
clarity in all of the theaters that
aren't perfectly aligned when i saw
interstellar i saw it in 70 millimeter
imax so i got to
see and hear the film the way
christopher nolan intended but when i
saw
tenet i saw it at a lower end local
theater whose projection and sound
quality
are subpar even compared to other
smaller theaters
and watching tennis i really had a hard
time
understanding a lot of the dialogue
you first so what's the solution here is
nolan making
a valid creative choice or does he need
to change his ways
making the choice to make some dialogue
unintelligible is a valid creative
technique that any filmmaker is welcome
to use but
a filmmaker declaring their intent and
the audience
perceiving the intended effect are two
different things
i'm not saying the audience is always
right but if a large portion of your
audience is repeatedly misunderstanding
your creative intent
you might want to re-examine how you're
using that technique
if audience members are confused about
whether or not they're supposed to be
able to hear a line of dialogue
they'll be thinking about that and not
about the effect nolan
is trying to get across basically how
intense
the emotion or sound is in that scene
one of the big differences between the
on the waterfront clip and some of the
places where nolan is using this
technique
is that in on the waterfront it's very
clear we're not supposed to be able to
hear this line and because of the way
the story is constructed we already kind
of know what he's saying
in nolan's films it's not always clear
if the dialogue that you can't hear
is important or not i don't think
confusion is the effect that nolan
is going for and so if most people are
perceiving it that way
he's essentially trying to produce a
certain effect and failing
that said sometimes audiences are too
conservative and
are shocked or confused by new
techniques when they're introduced to
them
but eventually assimilate that into
their understanding of film language but
this is a complicated issue
because it doesn't end there we have to
examine the other
aspect if no one says trust me if you
can't hear a line of dialogue it's
because i
intend for you not to hear it and then
turns around and mixes his films in such
a way that in a lot of theaters you
can't even hear the dialogue he intends
for you to hear
audiences are going to lose trust in his
creative voice i didn't get to see tenet
in
imax so it's hard for me to know if it
was
actually any clearer in a better aligned
higher end theater but it seems to me
that nolan is
alienating a large portion of his
audience in order to make
the experience as good as possible for
a very small group of people the crazy
irony is that in my video about tenant i
argue that christopher nolan has a big
problem with
exposition and when i watched tennant in
theaters because i couldn't hear
a lot of the dialogue i missed a lot of
the exposition
and i almost enjoyed the film more than
when i watched it at home and could turn
subtitles on
and could read every word because in my
opinion
a lot of the exposition actually hurts
the experience of the movie
but even though those lines may not
truly be necessary
if you feel like you're supposed to be
able to hear them and you can't
it makes watching the film a little bit
uncomfortable
and i'm generally a fan of filmmakers
pushing boundaries
artistically but if the way they're
going about pushing those boundaries
causes the audience to reject that
technique
instead of broadening their view of what
is
valid as a part of film language then it
feels counterproductive
it's easy to give supremacy to the
artistic
vision of the filmmaker but sometimes
artists
even successful ones make bad creative
choices
ultimately it's nolan's right to make
the creative decisions that he wants to
make
and it's the audience's right to stop
seeing his films if they're bothered by
them
and it's the critic and everyone's right
to discuss what makes for a good and bad
experience
watching a film as we all collectively
bargain about what makes a good film
i doubt nolan will change his ways and
in the book the nolan variations
he makes this comment i actually got
calls from other filmmakers who would
say
i just saw your film and the dialogue is
inaudible well i love that nolan is
trying to push the boundaries of what's
possible with sound and i think it works
in some
cases i think it's probably time he took
a note
from his peers mubi is a hand curated
online streaming platform that has an
excellent selection of movies a verna
hertzog documentary from 2019 that i
haven't seen yet called nomad in the
footsteps of bruce chatwin
is dropping on mubi next week and i'm
very excited to check it out because i'm
a big fan of hersog's work
every day movie handpicks and adds a new
film for you to watch and they have a
lot of cool stuff coming out this month
sundance 2021 just happened and movies
running a series of favorites from past
sundance festivals this month the
variety of stuff they have available is
really great and i find myself
discovering things on mubi
that i wouldn't find any other way not
long ago i watched a concert film they
have called tripping with nils fram that
was a really entertaining watch
mubi is one of the best streaming
services for exploring the world of
cinema
and you can try it now for 30 days when
you go to
mubi.com thomasflight get your extended
30 day free trial by clicking the link
in the description below
or going to mubi.com thomasflight thanks
again to mubi for sponsoring this video
and thank you to all of you for watching
special thank you to my patrons and i'll
catch you next time